안녕하세요, 제 이름은 데이비드 브라운입니다. 본 수업은 읽기 쓰기 수업입니다.
여러분의 의사소통에서 설득력을 갖추는 것은 여러분 자신, 학업, 미래의
경력 등에 유용할 것입니다.
의사소통에서 더 설득력을 갖추는 것이 여러분에게 유용할 것입니다.
더 설득력이 있다는 것은 다른 사람들이 여러분이 원하는 것을 하도록 만들 수 있다는 의미입니다.
여러분이 원하는 것을 하도록요, 정확합니다.
어떻게 하면 더 설득력을 가질 수 있을까요?
글쎄요, 배워야 합니다. 사람들이 말하길, 제가 듣기로는, 일단 대화하는 상대를 알게 되면,
그들이 더 잘 이해할 수 있도록 그들이 말하는 방식과 똑같이 말하는 법을 배워야 한다고 합니다.
하지만 동시에, 그들의 동일한 단어와 그들이 말하는 동일한 방식으로,
여러분은 그들에게 무언가를 가르쳐야 합니다.
그리고 일단 가르치면, 그들은 여러분을 따를 수 있게 될 것입니다.
제 생각에는 모든 사람이 능력만 있다면 우리를 설득할 수 있는 무언가를 가지고 있다고 생각합니다.
그렇게 할 수 있는 능력, 즉 잘 말하고 자신을 잘 표현할 수 있는 의사소통 기술 말입니다.
쉽지 않죠.
네, 쉽지 않습니다. 동의합니다.
어려울 수 있습니다.
그리고 이것은 우리가 개선할 수 있는 부분입니다.
우리는 의사소통에서 더 설득력을 갖추는 방법을 배울 수 있습니다.
그리고 프레더릭 더글러스가 우리에게 가르쳐주는 것이 있는데, 그의 자서전을 읽어보시면, 오늘 저희가 그 일부를
읽을 텐데요, 그가 얼마나 설득력 있는지 알게 될 것입니다.
그는 정말 훌륭한 작가이고, 이 대의를 위한 정말 위대한 설득력 있는 작가입니다.
그리고 그의 말은 그가 매우 설득력이 있었기 때문에 큰 영향을 미쳤습니다.
자, 요약하자면, 프레더릭 더글러스는 정확히 누구였을까요?
여기 이미지 콜라주를 보실 수 있습니다.
이것은 남북전쟁 이전, 남북전쟁 시대의 것입니다.
여기 이 사진에서 노예제 폐지론자들의 다른 예들을 볼 수 있습니다.
그는 1818년에 태어나 1895년에 사망했습니다.
그의 전성기는 남북전쟁 기간이었으며, 그는 아프리카계 미국인 사회 개혁가, 노예제 폐지론자,
웅변가, 작가, 그리고 정치가였습니다.
여기 이 부분을 읽어주시겠어요?
메릴랜드에서 노예 생활에서 탈출한 후, 그는 노예제 폐지 운동의 전국적인 지도자가 되었습니다.
그의 강력한 연설과 글로 유명했죠?
훌륭합니다. 사실, 에이브러햄 링컨도 이 사람에 대해 알고 있었고 그의 글을 읽었습니다.
그리고 그가 이 운동에 동참하도록 영감을 준 것이 바로 그의 글 일부였습니다.
자, 여기 차트가 있습니다.
우리는 프레더릭 더글러스에 대해 이미 알고 있는 것,
어쩌면 제가 이미 말씀드린 것이나, 전에 들어보셨던 것, 또는
남북전쟁에 대해 이미 알고 있는 것에 대해 생각해 볼 것입니다. 이 노예제 폐지론자나 남북전쟁에 대해 이미 무엇을 알고 계신가요?
선생님께서 말씀해주신 바로는, 음, 그는 아프리카계 미국인이고, 노예였습니다.
그는 다른 사람들로부터 읽는 법을 배웠습니다.
읽는 법을 배운 것이 아니라, 다른 사람들이 읽는 것을 들으면서 배웠다고 하셨죠, 맞나요?
그리고 그는 77세에 사망했고, 메릴랜드에서 노예 생활에서 탈출했습니다.
그리고 일단 읽는 법을 배우고 나서는, 그는 유명한 였습니다.
그는 유명한 작가였습니다.
작가요. 유명한 노예제 폐지론자이자 작가였습니다. 훌륭합니다.
잘 들으셨네요. 감사합니다.
자, 이제 여기서 배울 새로운 것들이 있습니다. 프레더릭 더글러스에 대해 어떤 질문이 있으신가요?
그에 대해 어떤 것들을 알고 싶으신가요?
아.
네, 그가 노예 생활에서 탈출했다고 되어 있는데요. 그 후에 그는 무엇을 했나요?
네.
그리고 어떻게 알아낼 수 있을 것 같나요? 음, 제 생각에는 오늘 수업과 활동을 통해 알아낼 수 있을 것 같습니다만,
사실 오늘 우리가 읽을 내용은 그가 탈출하기 전의 생각과 더 관련이 있습니다.
그래도 그가 무엇을 해야 했는지, 또는 무엇이 그를 탈출할 수 있게 이끌었는지에 대해 어느 정도 짐작할 수 있을 거라고 생각합니다.
그리고 이것은 어쩌면 여러분이 오늘 이 수업 후에
그의 자서전을 마저 읽고 싶다면 읽어볼 수 있는 또 다른 내용이기도 합니다.
그리고 그의 글 일부도요. 자, 우리가 집중해야 할 몇 가지 어휘가 있습니다. 우리는 프레더릭 더글러스의 자서전에서
한 구절을 읽을 텐데요, 거기서 그는 읽고 쓰는 법을 배우려는 자신의 결의를 묘사합니다.
아무것도 이 사람을 막을 수 없었습니다. 그는 자신을 교육하기 위해 할 수 있는 모든 것을 했습니다.
노예가 읽고 쓰는 법을 배우는 것이 매우 금기시되던 세상에서 말이죠.
네. 이것들은 우리가 여기서 알아야 할 몇 가지 어휘들입니다. 여러분이 이것들과
그 정의들을 살펴보셨으면 합니다. 'strategies'(전략)가 있습니다. 여기 정의를 읽어주시겠어요?
교묘한 속임수. 교묘한 속임수 또는 목표 달성을 위해 사용되는 계획.
'Depravity'(타락).
잘 안 보이는데요. 도덕적 부패 또는 사악함. 사악함.
이것은요. 'Chattel'(동산). 첫 번째 항목인데, 어떻게 발음하나요?
'Chattel'(채틀). 'Chattel'. 프랑스어 같죠, 그렇죠?
물품 또는 개인 재산. 노예가 된 사람들은 법적으로
'chattel'(동산)로 간주되었습니다. 그러니까 기본적으로 가치 없는 물건과 같은 것이죠. 그들은 단지
물건, 사용하고 버릴 수 있는 것들로 취급받았습니다. 그리고 이것, 'precepts'(교훈). 'Precepts'.
행동을 인도하는 규칙이나 원칙. 'Apprehension'(염려/이해).
들리시나요.
'Apprehension'(염려/이해). 들리시나요? 'Apprehension'.
두려움. 이제 들립니다. 나쁜 일이 일어날 것이라는 두려움과 불안. 또한 이해.
아니요. 'Urchins'(개구쟁이들).
'Urchins'(개구쟁이들) 장난기 많은. 아니요, 어떻게 발음하는지 모르겠어요.
'Mischievous'(미스치버스). 'Mischievous'.
종종 가난하고 허름한 옷을 입은 아이들.
'sea urchins'(성게)도 있죠. 성게는 가시가 돋친 바다 생물의 한 종류입니다.
하지만 아이들을 묘사할 때 'urchins'라고 장난스럽게, 또는 애정 어린 표현으로도 쓸 수 있습니다.
그리고 이것, 'vindication'(옹호/입증). 'Vindication'.
그리고 ‘정당성 입증’(vindication). 누군가의 비난을 벗겨주는 것. 아, 그리고 누군가 또는 무언가가
옳거나 합리적이라는 증거. 그리고 'abhor'(혐오하다). 'Abhor'. 혐오와 증오심을 가지고 대하다.
그리고 증오심.
그래서 우리는 이것을 동사로 사용합니다. 무언가를 'abhor'(혐오하다), 무언가를 정말로 싫어하다.
그래서 이 단어들 중 많은 것들이 우리가 함께 읽으면서 이야기할
몇 가지 사항들을 정말로 강조합니다. 우리가 읽을 때, 의미에 집중하려고 노력할 것입니다. 제가 발음을 도와드릴 수는 있지만,
그것이 방해되기를 원하지는 않습니다.